i know that sounds completely crazy but
every high performing athlete does it
every salesperson does it i mean at high
level
i don't believe in being fearless i
think if you're fearless it means that
you
are just doing the things that are
inside your comfort zone when you're on
a path of purpose
you ain't got time for drama
rise and shine it says special time
hey it's evan carmichael and i am not a
morning person
but when you start your day off with a
powerful routine that
inspires you like watching one of these
videos it will
change your life so let's start your day
off right together grab your cup of
coffee know that i believe in you
and get ready for a shot of espresso
from brendon burchard
i wake up every morning
research study in psychology found out
that both second person and third person
makes you more it makes yourself talk
more powerful so if you're gonna do
affirmations
you wouldn't just say i wanna do this i
wanna do this you wanna do what
we call in the book self coaching where
you would say
you know in my case yeah brendan it's
important you do a good job here today
because you usually don't do interviews
and you really love marie and you want
to do a good job for her and her people
and this is a book you worked on for
three years and it's important it does
well
and brendan don't forget you're so lucky
you get to do this brother
so just enjoy the process you're so
lucky brendan
that's a different level of going i'm
lucky i'm lucky right
it is i'm brendan yes yes another one
another one i do every morning
yeah assuming i take a shower but every
morning in the shower because we all
don't every day
not every morning no we do not this
doesn't happen it does not happen
i told you like 24 hours ago i was
staying in a barn in the woods at a
friend's house
um but the second thing i ask myself in
the in the shower every morning
is what might happen today that could
trip me up
and how are you going to bring your best
self to that brendan
i say that every morning in the shower
to myself and it just helps me
anticipate
you know something's going to go wrong
during the day absolutely and if i
already know
everything like like this morning's was
okay
you're in i think what we would i think
i'm yes north
manhattan where i'm staying what do you
call it north you're uptown
i'm uptown and you're coming to um let's
just call it downtown
okay so i'm like okay that's gonna be 45
minutes it's a hot summer day
yes i'm gonna get hot and i know when
i'm hot sometimes i get
impatient yes and i get stressed and i
don't want to feel that so just pay
attention to how you're feeling on your
way down to the interview with marie
brendan
and really just engage pay attention be
present with new york and really enjoy
that you're here
i know that sounds completely crazy but
every high performing athlete does it
every salesperson does it i mean at high
level
every person i interviewed who are at
what we call the top 15
of all high performers they all
self-talk and most of them we found
we're doing it in second and third
person which is amazing i love it yeah i
think it's so fun
yeah little things yeah so if you
already talk to yourself
and you say your name to yourself and
they're not crazy you're probably high
performing
most of us never take control of our
self-talk you don't
take control of the thoughts that you
have about yourself when you're by
yourself
it doesn't even matter as much what our
parents think what our friends think
what our
husband or wife thinks it's you you're
the problem
you think negatively about yourself you
are not consistently filling yourself
with
thoughts with positivity with ambition
with courage
the default pattern is one of mediocrity
of one of
i can't do this one of lack of
resourcefulness and so that's what you
live
and it's possible to change and in
making that shift and making that change
you become
an entirely different person we talk
about how to become the best version of
yourself
how do you live your life how do you how
do you show up as that proud version
this is it it's taking control of the
automatic
self-talk that you have to yourself even
if you don't actually talk to yourself
even if you're not saying evan you're an
idiot
right evan you can't do that even if
you're not saying those things out loud
you're feeling those things it's at a
subconscious level
and this is where you're playing small
and they've been limiting yourself so
let me share example from from my
background and then also give you some
tactical specific tangible things you
can do
to start to break free to start to
actually live the life that you say that
you want to live
i i'm afraid a lot
i'm afraid a lot and i used to let that
fear dominate me
i used to let that fear prevent me from
doing the thing that i needed to do
whether it's making videos whether it's
speaking on stage whether it's
interviewing people
i don't believe in being fearless i
think if you're fearless it means that
you
are just doing the things that are
inside your comfort zone you're
photocopying your life i think if you're
fearless you actually hate your life
because you're just doing things that
you know how to do i think fear is a
great thing
it's not being fearless it's having the
fear
and then showing up because of not even
despite of because of because you're
afraid then you have to go do the thing
because you're worried then you have to
go do the thing because you're
afraid of somebody's judgment and you
have to go to just because just to teach
yourself that you do it so
for me speaking on stage doing
interviews making videos were the three
that i
struggled with the most this guy who's
made ten thousand videos has spoken in
front of thousands of people have done
interviews with
some of the biggest people on the planet
i'm still afraid every time
i'm still afraid every time and i don't
let that fear now stop me from doing the
thing i'm still
you know i had tony robbins on my
channel and i had them on three years or
two years before
but i'm still nervous to have them on my
heart's still beating my crazy i'm still
an emotional wreck the day of i'm still
not focused
on anything else i can't do any other
work i can't make any other videos
because i'm
i'm stressed about the interview going
well i still worry about these things
it doesn't go away there's just levels
to this
and i still want to show up where old
evan
younger evan used to find a reason why i
couldn't do it
find a reason why i couldn't show up
live in the fear
and justify it as an actual reason or
excuse but deep down
i was just afraid think about your
reasons like why can't you do this thing
what are you telling yourself that you
can't do really deep down
it's just a fear you're just afraid
there's no really good reason you've
convinced yourself there's a reason
but deep down you're just afraid right
if you're actually honest with yourself
you're just afraid
so how do you get out of it how do you
start to shift the narrative how do you
start to
identify the self-talk that's been
automatic and in your brain
consistently for years or maybe decades
how do you start to make that shift
happen
number one is to spend a little time
with yourself
and and finish the sentence i am what i
am blank
i am blank what's the blank you are what
if you're just by yourself you have a
little
space to breathe from your environment
you are what what are some of the
words that come up what are some of the
positive words what are some of the
negative words that show up
if you're being honest with yourself
there'll be hope for some positive ones
so
um for me it could be i'm someone who
believes
i am uh i am a great husband
so i'm paying attention i am you know a
great father i am
a great not owner what do you do with
dogs i don't know like great
they still consider your kids they're my
kids yeah dark kids
pet kids all right you know i am i bet
then on the negative side like i
am uh afraid of disappointing people
i am scared of speaking on stages i'm
worried that i'm gonna ask bad interview
questions like what are the positive and
negatives
if you feel in the i am okay just to get
awareness of yourself
this starts to uncover some of the
subconscious behavior that you're living
on autopilot right the subconscious is
the autopilot it's what you're doing by
default
the conscious is what we want to take
control of to then turn into
subconscious
to then make the automatic
the positive the ambitious the bold the
courageous right
so start with i am what that does is
lead you to step two which allows you to
identify your trigger words
so what are the trigger words that you
use
consistently as an excuse for you not to
do the thing
so my three trigger words are scary
difficult or hard
that when i say scary difficult
hard those used to be
the reasons why i couldn't do something
those used to be the reasons why i would
let myself off the hook those used to be
the things that would tell myself oh i
can't do this because it's scary i can't
do this because it's difficult
i won't show up because it's hard and i
would let myself off the hook for those
things that i would say oh that's okay
because it's scary so
i'm not going to do it and and i would
that used to be my identity
and identifying the trigger words what
then allows you to do is move the step
number three
where you use them to take the action
that you want to take instead
that when you're thinking it because
those are the automatic patterns that
are in your head your subconscious great
when i say those things when i feel
those things when i text those things
when i write those things and i have a
conversation those things
come out of my mouth come out of my
brain if i'm thinking about it to myself
then i have to do it just because scary
difficult or hard
and what that does and that's those are
mine and you can adopt them as your own
but i'd rather you go through the i
am process to figure out what they are
for you what it does is help you
live the life that you're proud of that
when you say oh that's that's just too
hard
you're not allowed to say that anymore
you're not allowed to say that feel that
think that
as soon as you say it then you have to
immediately go do the thing even if it
doesn't work out even if you look like a
fool even if
even if xyz happens you're gonna do it
it's worth it
because you're you're reprogramming your
identity
as a bonus step you tell the people
around you
so nina nina stepped out but uh nina
my son my team my family i'll let them
know hey if i say scary difficult or
hard i want you to let me know
if i say to you in any conversation
i can't because it's scary or it's
difficult or it's hard i need you to
call me out on it
because i'm not i still don't catch all
of them
it's a lot more than it used to be
and i'm probably i don't know 90 95
percent
of the way there but there'll still be
some small percentage and having people
hold you accountable
is really important now the default
thinking for them is gonna be what are
you talking about
you're always doing all of these things
you're always showing up you're always
doing
scary difficult hard in in my case
yeah but not like i could be there's
there's another level to this
and everything i want out of life my
mission my my
vision my boldness is on the other side
my great life is on the other side of
even more
scary difficult and hard
i have to start living it and so i need
help in catching it
so you use yourself as as step one as
the first part but then if you can
as a bonus bring in the accountability
to the other people in your life
who can help you catch it and you're not
allowed to get angry at them
you're not allowed to get frustrated at
them if if you say
one of your trigger words and they say
you just said it
you're gonna wanna say nah but she's
this
that doesn't count it doesn't mean it i
i was thinking so stop letting yourself
off the hook
and said you say you're right i need to
go do the thing and the more you can
train that
trigger word came up i'm doing the thing
trigger word came up and doing the thing
trigger work him up and do the thing
it's scary i'm doing it it's difficult
i'm doing it's hard i'm doing it
just because you start shifting your
identity you start changing your
self-talk
now you start to become the person that
you're proud of you start to become the
person that you
you say you want to be you start to
actually become
the person you've become the best
version of you
that's how you tangibly change your
self-talk
tangibly change the thoughts that are
running your system that are keeping you
small
keeping you scared keeping you way below
your potential
and when everybody else in the world is
letting you off the hook saying what a
great job you're doing
you know that you keep full of more you
know that when you sit down by yourself
when you look in the mirror there's not
all love there
right you love yourself do you see love
when you look back in the mirror when
you do the im exercise
is it only positive we have to start
getting honest with ourselves
this is the process to change it and if
you did that every day
you're not going to catch it all the
time don't worry about being perfect
this isn't a game about being perfect
it's about making progress it's about
taking the step
every day building momentum if you did
that if you could just find your trigger
words
and then every day that you catch it do
something about it even if it's some
small thing
your entire life will change the way you
show up in your life in your
relationships in your business
towards your customers towards your team
all of it all of it changes
all of it changes suddenly you're not
impaired anymore
suddenly you're a lot more creative
where did it come from where did this
extra courage come from
how am i not handicapped anymore by the
things that used to
slow me down this will be you
and i want you to get there faster and
this is the process to do it so you can
start living the life
that you know you're capable of change
your self-talk
change your life good luck now i've got
a special bonus clip that i think you're
gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week when you just get
motivated when you watch a video like
this you just get motivated
the sign says you have a 35 chance of
actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
are a bunch of action takers it has to
happen
so here's how you do it when you
actually create a plan when you write
down
what time what place where you're
actually going to take action
your number jumps from 35 to 91
chance of following through and when you
commit to other people
like leaving a comment down below your
number jumps to 95
chance of following through i want that
for you so believe nation your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action
for the next week i'm going to take one
of your comments and feature it in a
future video
so i can celebrate you let me know in
the comments below listen
humans are built to serve some people
are built to serve the world
others want to serve the 25 people
closest to them
but in either case humans are built to
serve so if you're not happy right now
it's because you're not serving enough
you've got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute
to make a difference to make an impact
and this is your field guide for
i believe in your kid i remember when i
was going to start my business
and i i really wanted to be good at it
you know i was
trying to become an author and a speaker
and do these types of videos and
do some online training for people on
the topics of motivation
and marketing and you know some all
these people are saying well brendan
you know you may or may not be
successful with that you're you know
blah blah and i thought
it's a weird thing it's not like there's
a trait of successful people you look
across
history and successful people it's not
they're not from a given background
they don't come from a specific economic
stature they're not in a position where
you know they're they're one demographic
or another democrat i mean it's all over
i mean we've got thousands of collective
years of history people succeed
some people do some people don't and i
think it more comes down to
how do we manage our mind and how do we
manage our days
and i think that there's a difference
between successful people and
unsuccessful people in the way they
particularly think about
um approaching something new you know i
think unsuccessful people
when they have a big dream and they
start thinking about what's going to be
required
to accomplish that dream they get very
limiting in their beliefs about
themselves and what's possible
and specifically they say three types of
things you know the first thing they
often say is well
you know i don't know how to do that so
they stop
they say you know i i don't have those
things
so they stop or they say i don't know
you know i'm not like those people i'm
not like that
and so they stop but successful people
have a different way the same thing
everybody dreams you dream i dream
successful people dream people just
starting out everybody dreams
everyone has a vision everyone if they
can just take five minutes today and
think about
their lives we could all come up with
ways to improve our lives and reach
another level of
success joy happiness achievement
contribution
fulfillment soul you know we can all
elevate
but the challenge is that the
unsuccessful people they keep stopping
when they think of what they currently
know have
or are but successful people say well i
want to do that
but i don't know how to do that but
instead of stopping they say
well then my job is to go learn that
they take their current limitation and
they put it on their agenda
as a job to do as a thing to figure out
a thing to make happen
instead of saying well i don't have that
they say well then my
job is to go build that or i'm not like
that then they say well then my job is
to go
become more of that become that person
who could accomplish those things
you know when i was starting to do
online marketing for the first time and
and i don't know if you how much of my
story you know but when i started doing
online marketing i was literally
bankrupt
and i went from a place of bankruptcy to
the point where i really committed to
becoming successful at it
and in 18 months i made 4.8 million
dollars uh 4.6 collected i mean it was a
huge leap right in in difference from
bankrupt to multi-millionaire span of 18
months
but what made that breakthrough wasn't
that i had new opportunities
it wasn't that i had new technologies it
was like wow there's the internet now
those things were already there it went
i went from this level of thinking
to this level of thinking i used to say
well i i don't know how to build a web
page
so i said agenda figure out how to build
a web page and i spent
hours and hours and hours at nights on
weekends from my job figuring out how to
do that
and i said well i don't have one of
those lists you know i don't have any
subscribers nobody knows who i am so i
said
job go build a list go
get subscribers go add value and content
out the marketplace and they'll come i
mean just keep putting stuff
out there and i also didn't say oh my
gosh well
i have that dream i can't have that
because i'm not like that
because i wasn't a public speaker i
didn't know how to do video i wasn't
like well i'm not one of those video
people
well i'm not a public speaker so i said
you know what
i have to go learn that art i have to go
become a better speaker a better
communicator
i have to go become more confident i
have to go become a person capable of
doing these things
i have to change myself to get there i
can't wait for circumstances to change
so i can have my dream
then our dreams would never happen we
have to get to the point of maturity in
our lives where we say okay
two things are gonna change my life
something new is gonna come into my life
and make me lucky and blessed
and maybe i can't count on that forever
and maybe now instead i have to
consciously design my life and say okay
now if i want to change if i want my
dream
something new has to come from me i'm
going to become
a better person i'm going to become a
person who is more optimistic who is
more confident
who is more driven not because i am that
now but because we can grow
that you can become the type of person
who needs to
uh who you need to be to achieve your
ideal life
you can start today living from your
highest ideals
your highest sense of self your
strongest sense of self you don't need
permission you don't need a guy like me
to look at the video camera and say you
have now permission but if you've been
waiting for it
you have permission it's like at some
point in your life you just say okay
i have permission to become my best self
and by becoming your
best self you start to achieve your best
things you start to contribute
better things you start to become a
better human being you can do that now
today
so next time you're thinking about a big
dream don't think about the things that
well i don't know how to do that
and stop think i don't know how so set
it up on your calendar to go
learn those things i don't have that
then set it up
step by step to go build that i'm not
like that then set it up step by step to
go develop those skill sets
and those competencies so you can become
that and ultimately
you can achieve that dream it's there
it's waiting for you
don't stop now i know you all have big
goals big dreams big aspirations just
like i do
you've got ambitions to become an
amazing person to build your career to
create
contribute to give to be an awesome
human being
but all of that is impossible without
great habits set up if you don't have
routine and structure set up in a way
that will keep you on track then you'll
fall off and and having new goals
without new habits is kind of like
you know having a new car without wheels
you know
the habits are the wheels they are the
things that make you able
to achieve the goals so you got to have
good habits
but the challenge for most people isn't
that knowledge i mean you know you need
to have good habits
it's you can't keep the habit going
right
have you ever started it the new year
you're going to get healthier and you
start that habit of working out more on
a more regular basis
and then it goes away or you say you
know i'm gonna be more kind and more
patient and more awesome to my partner
my lover
and you start being nice for two or
three days and then on the fourth day
you're a jerk you know and you're like
what happened i said i was gonna be
nicer it's that you didn't set up the
most
important thing you needed to maintain a
habit
so what's the biggest secret i've
learned in almost 20 years
in this field it's so simple but most
people don't have it
it's called trigger moments you have to
set up
trigger moments to activate your habits
what do i mean by that well let's say
you want to become
a better person you know you want to
become more kind
more patient more loving with people now
you can just set that intention or write
that down in your
vision in your your journal or set up on
a vision board that you look at once in
a while
but in day to day life it's not enough
you need things to trigger you to remind
you
to be that particular kind of person
right
it's almost like if you could have a
little angel speaking in your ear all
day long
to tell you what to do and how to be
you'd obviously become
better well that makes sense well let's
use that idea
let's use that idea by setting up alarms
on our phones that trigger us to do the
very things we need to do this is gonna
be so basic you're gonna laugh
and then also tell you how i literally
taught this to fortune 50 ceos
and they said it was the one thing that
changed their life the most dramatically
so let's start with this let's have a
goal in mind let's say you want to
become
more present and calm throughout the day
again you could write that down on a
journal i'm going to be more present and
calm
you could meditate in the morning saying
today i'm going to be more present
and calm and you could you could start
out with good intentions
but those fall apart without a trigger
moment set up throughout the day to
remind you that
so what if you did this what if you just
set up on your phone three alarms during
the day with a label
that said close your eyes take
10 deep breaths in remind yourself to be
calm
so let's say you're going through your
day it's crazy right it's 10 a.m and
also
being your phone goes off you look down
and it says close your eyes
take 10 deep breaths and then again it
happens at
two o'clock and again it happens at six
pm
and again it happens at eight pm what's
gonna happen
you always look at your phone don't you
it's gonna go throughout the day you're
gonna forget and the funniest thing is
i've had so many people do this
worldwide we're talking about hundreds
of thousands of people i've talked to do
this
hundreds of thousands and they tell me
all the time that changed everything
and you'll think once you set it up that
the next day you you'll you'll
forget about it no that alarm will go
off you forgot you set the dang alarm
there it goes off in your face you're
like all right i'm trying to be
calmer and more present close my eyes
take 10 deep breaths re-ground myself
here we go
you can't do it once a day you have to
have moments throughout the day that
trigger you to enact the new behavior
i know this makes sense to you but it's
a challenge for a lot of people because
they never set those things up
so what if you did it with an alarm so
for example for me on the opposite
spectrum i don't want to just be calmer
and more present i want more energy
throughout the day so here's what i do
one of my big trigger moments is
every time my butt hits a chair i don't
care if i'm on a plane
or i was like where we're shooting here
i i wrote a lot of my books here i wrote
the motivation manifesto here
i wrote the charge here and if i'm going
to write
my butt hits the chair i grab my phone i
open the timer and i set
50 minutes now at 50 minutes the
timer goes it starts buzzing and i look
at that and i go oh
that's my trigger to get energy so i
stand up i go get some water
i take a glass of water drink it down i
do some stretches
and i do some exercise just really
briefly or i'll go for a walk whatever
it is but i'll do something
that usually takes just two to five
minutes then i'll sit back down
i'll set that 50 min alarm and i'll work
and what that does is every 50 minutes
it triggers me
to change how i'm physically moving it
changes my attention
so that throughout the day i'm
continually refreshed
so i never have that two three four
o'clock time where i'm like ah
you know why because i've triggered my
day so
that my energy is maintained throughout
the day makes sense right
this could be as simple as let's say you
want to be healthier
in your life okay let's set up some
trigger moments for you
in this way let's say every time you
drop off the kids
on the way back to the house you stop at
the grocery store and get some fresh
produce
that's just a trigger it's like okay did
one thing
drop kids off now tied to that triggered
from that action
drop kids off is go to health food store
or let's say you want to get healthier
in the morning one of the easiest ways
to help people maintain a better
exercise program is this
set a trigger you wake up in the morning
your first action is to drink water
put your exercise shoes on might get
dressed if you're naked just saying so
you get dressed put your shoes on
you go downstairs or you go to the gym
and
that's the trigger you woke up you do
these actions nothing interrupts those
actions that's the action
and you have to have those set up one of
my other
favorite trigger moments to set up is
door frame triggers what do you mean by
that when you walk
into a new room to have a psychological
trigger go off in your mind
that you've associated with that door
frame so let me give you an example
if i walk into my house at night after
like if i've been working
all day and i'm gonna walk in i'm gonna
see my lady i have it so when i
ever walk through the doors of my house
three words repeat
off immediately in my mind because i've
done it so many times consciously
i went to the door i said the three
words said three words said the three
words
and i did this so many times that now
when i walk through a door
my mind automatically triggers those
three words
and i remember to be those three words
so what words would you love to have
describe you as a person that you would
be happy if that was
how people described you what would
those words be
have those and now set them up in your
life i teach executives do this as well
i have them have a door frame trigger
when they walk into their office in the
morning
as soon as they walk through that door
frame they have boom three words go
through their mind about how they want
to be perceived as a leader
i have them set up another door every
time they walk into a meeting into the
conference room
when they walk through the doors of the
conference room they have another three
words that trigger off for them
and it just reminds them how to be
so these aren't big crazy things a lot
of people they think they have to
completely change their life
what would change your life completely
is setting
up more trigger moments and associations
that when you see something you do this
that when this action is taken
then that happens that when you uh have
the opportunity to set up alarms on your
phone you set them up
so that you're interrupted in your
everyday life
to remind yourself to stick to the
habits
to stick to the intention you do that
enough on a continual basis
you'll find yourself in so many ways
completely
rejuvenated and i promise you'll stick
to your habits
even more and once you do that you know
that everything
changes you have to be all in and it's
the hardest thing to do because
if it fails then you can feel like a
failure um
you know i think of this idea of
performance necessity
um two stories kind of come to mind one
is i was working with an olympic gold
medalist sprinter
and we're in the tunnel and we're going
out and he's talking about the
competition
and we get out to the blocks and i said
uh he was really worried about the
competition i said well how do you
engage like
who who who's going to win you know
in in his particular race people are
winning but by
you know 1 100th of a second tenths of a
seconds i mean
these are really close sprints and i
said well how how do you know
i said who would you even bet on and he
says
you know i would bet on the guy
who gets down at the blocks gets himself
settled looks at the finish line then
says
i gotta do this for my mom
and i was like oh that's good his
performance necessity in that is
it's necessary for him to win that race
for his mom
um i think of you know when i started
my career and i really decided to go all
in
with writing and online training this is
like 2000
probably six uh i'd gone broke
completely bankrupt and failed i left my
corporate job i had this cushy kind of
corporate job as a consultant
good job um left it to write and i
didn't know how to make it as a writer
i want to do seminars workshops didn't
know how to do that so i was
pretty much a hot mess ran out of money
um
i got nothing to my name nothing
kind of no positive prospects no one's
calling
me except the guys who want the money
and um
one night i'm riding and the apartment
was so small on the bed
i had uh all you know my bills
my vision boards all my research all my
journals like the bed was basically the
desk the extended desk
and my lady comes in denise and
she walks past me but she sees i'm like
trying to write
she doesn't want to disturb me she goes
she crawls under
the covers of the bed and i'm just
typing kind of
casually typing away and i look over
and i see my woman
sleeping under my bills
and it was just like
you know because none of us want to see
our you know
our family suffer because we are not
performing
sure and um
i was just like
i gotta figure this out and i'm telling
you i wrote more that night
than any night in my entire life next
day i wrote more than ever that bird's
life
scolding ticket which gave me a
bestseller and in
you know 18 months later because i was
like i'm going to figure out this online
thing i mean throughout marketing i'm
going to figure out
how to teach i'm going to how to train
and get paid for it because i've never
really been paid for those things i said
i'm going to figure out this industry
and i'm gonna make it
18 months later after her crawling under
the bills
i made 4.6 million dollars jesus
online total transformation people like
how did you do it
i'm like she gave me and she was my
necessity
i was not going to let my woman be in
that situation
um and she believed in me she supported
me she
she married me and uh you know
but that was she was my drive and the
second part was i went all in with my
identity
i said i am going to be a great writer
and i am going to be one of the greatest
online trainers there ever was
you know as you said in the intro now
we've graduated over two million
people have taken our online courses
video series now
i don't think it would have happened if
i hadn't had the guts
and maybe the no other choice
to say this is who i'm going to be and
i'm going to build
into that and it's necessary for me to
become
that person so let's go you know the
first way you should not
compare yourself to others is in terms
of especially today
their fans their fame their followership
right their audience never do that in my
industry that's very very popular to do
and it's ruined a lot of people's lives
who don't
ever rise up to serve because they think
they're not popular enough
you know it's like that you write your
first book and you don't have as many
sales as other people and you think oh
well i don't have the audience
or you go to someone's fan page and you
see oh my gosh look at their
followership look at how many instagram
followers they have how many
twitter followers they have and and
because you see them so big you think oh
i could never be
that so you don't even begin and a lot
of people do that they say well i'm not
that big
so they never start but as i always say
you know what no matter how small you
start
start something that matters begin it
if i began my career looking at my
heroes looking at a wayne dyer
or a tony robbins or marianne williamson
a deepak chopra
a jim rohn back in the day or or looking
at people like augmentinos who'd sold
millions of books or
or even the famous books that you saw
millions and millions and millions of
copies if i
gauged myself to that and thought that
was the expectation
i would never begin so you can't expect
to start out
with tons of people some some people say
to me all the time well brendan it's so
easy for you because you got millions of
people on your email list and you have
millions of people on facebook and tens
of millions on youtube
i say it doesn't make it any harder for
me i still show up and shoot this video
and the reason i have the followers and
the fans
and the audience is because i showed up
and i started when there was only one
dude 10 dudes 100 dudes a thousand dudes
watching us
my first seminar that i ever did we we
only had 22 people
in the room and now we fill up seminars
nine times a year often from people from
46 countries around the world fly in
paying thousands of dollars a ticket and
what did i do
i i started with 22 people in a room and
most of those people didn't even pay
and every time the the guy walked in
with with water i counted him as one of
those 22.
you know like i i had no followership
it's never about
how big you start it's that you start
and you get big
by staying at it because what people do
is they put out the first video they
write the first book they
they try their first thing online and
nobody follows nobody watches and they
quit
they get disappointed and where there's
disappointment
there was too high of an expectation on
achievement
versus learning versus process versus
beginning
what you want to do is never be
disappointed and the way that you're
never disappointed is you understand
every single step
counts every single step is learning
every single step gets you going
but if you have the aspiration or the
the
attention that's only focused on their
followership and meeting that you'll
never begin
don't compare your followership to
anybody else's
instead just compare your work ethic be
there show up work get it done
the second thing i want you to compare
yourself to is other people's
achievements
that means their wealth their sales
number
their uh big house their big car their
whatever else you know their fancy
clothes they're whatever they got
don't look at other people's
achievements and what they have
because if you do that it's also you
think well i'm not famous enough and
then you think well i'm not
lucky enough blessed enough rich enough
whatever your excuse becomes
you got to get very very very careful of
that and i know you know that
but lately have you been looking at
other people's stuff
and feeling demoralized because of that
well i
you know they had a silver spoon in
their mouth or they're so lucky
those types of things stop us from even
trying because we feel like the game is
unfair
well it's not most wealthy people
especially all the billionaires i've met
and i've been less to meet lots of them
and coach a few of them
the mega stars i get to work with the
olympians i get to work with the highest
achieving people in the world
they it's not luck and most of them
didn't have unbelievable lucky family
connections
what they did is they hustled they
worked they built it
and even if they started a little more
abundant than other people
they outlasted their peers who also
started out abundant because they gave
they worked they struggled through
and we got to keep going the third thing
don't compare yourself ever
in terms of looks appearances beauty
you know i i know if you're somebody who
opens up those fashion magazines
or those celebrity gossip magazines
you're always looking oh she's cuter
than me
oh he's better looking and then again
you have the excuse
as soon as you compare yourself to other
people you have the excuse to never
begin
you have the reason to be demoralized i
mean there's if i looked across
youtube when i started doing my episodes
or my videos or
or itunes or podcasts you know
i would have never begun because you've
got all these people out there they're
like they're amazing
they look so good they sound so good and
i sucked
i couldn't talk like this before now as
you know all of our videos and every
episode i've ever done
has been unscripted no notes i got
nothing i'm looking right at you there's
nothing in front of me
i just go and they're all in one single
take majority of them i think
99 are one take
and that came from practice where for
years and years and years
years and years and years i i tried to
be able to just speak
extemporaneously without using notes
without using a script i taught myself
to do this
and if i compared myself to other people
who were so polished and looking good
and every word was
precise i would have never gotten to
where we're at today with
literally hundreds of millions of views
and
from our posts to our videos it came
because i didn't worry about the polish
of
looking like everybody else i was just
doing my thing
so what should you compare why should
you be comparing yourself to others
for growth reasons learning reasons i
mean
the first reason you should always
compare yourself to others is for
creativity
to get ideas not to steal
and not to compare but rather to go oh
how would i do that
it you know in comparing yourself to
others it brings in
self-awareness to say oh look this is
how i'm distinct
this is how i'm different this is how i
could approach this in a different way
if i didn't research the market i would
never know how i could be different
if i didn't know how it could be
different i could never have a business
you cannot build a business or have a
real career or make
any major contribution without
understanding how you're distinct
steve jobs knew that when he built the
phone it was different
and that thinking differently is what
made him an icon
it's the same for everything that we do
compare so you know what is out there
so you know how you can bring a new
creative edge to it second reason to
compare
is to compare for vision because
as you get self-awareness and you
understand how you're distinct sometimes
you see someone doing something amazing
and you're like
wow i got a bigger vision for myself
when i started seeing people posting
videos you know back in 2007
i got a bigger vision for myself i mean
2007 i saw people posting longer videos
online i thought
wow i never saw myself doing video but
look at how i'm watching these and i'm
relating with these i got to do some
video and by comparing myself to others
some other people i followed or
researched or read their books and i saw
they had a podcast i'm like
i'm going to get a podcast it opened up
my
vision for the vehicles the mediums the
the ways that i could serve and give and
i want you to do the same and
the last piece the reason to compare
yourself is for growth
there is an amazing amount of talent in
this world and
when you see them it should inspire you
to level up
it inspired me to learn how to do video
it inspired me to learn how to
speak extemporaneous and it inspired me
to get over my fears of public speaking
and step on a stage
and now it's in front of thousands and
thousands of people inspired the world
i never i never thought i could do that
but seeing other people
sometimes achieve the remarkable you get
inspired
if it's not about if you can look at
someone who's done something better than
you
and it inspires you that means you have
humility
and you got a chance if you look at
other people who've achieved more have
more look more
feel good or are more amazing than you
and you get bitter
or upset that means you're small
and you're destined to smallness but if
you can look at greatness and be
inspired
you're on track you're going to live an
extraordinary quality of life the kind
of life that we call
the charge life in our lives
especially when we're being reactive
information comes in right we're at
events
we're paying attention to how people
treat us
we're studying something we're trying to
learn something uh
and we're just going about a regular day
information is coming in
how people perceive us the cause and
effect of events
things are just happening information
comes into the brain
from that point the information
immediately
goes into interpretation
and what this usually means is
interpretation in the fast reactive
thing is
safe unsafe good
bad like it don't like it
recognize it don't recognize it
been there done that unfamiliar familiar
certain
uncertain fear safe all these things
start triggering
it's pretty unconscious and it's pretty
fast our biases come into play
it's just that speed spontaneous
reactive
part of us and it's that's not always
bad sometimes
it can be good right sometimes it can be
good interpretation can be
that event that's good for me or that
events that's bad for me
but usually it's like a snap judgment
think about that
most most when we're talking about an
unconscious level
it's like a snap judgment automatic like
you like her don't like her
feel safe don't feel safe it's very fast
then the next level
and this is not always linear of course
because your brain
is not left brain right brain
kind of methodology your brain's more of
a spider web of interconnectiveness
that is something we still don't
understand okay
you can study everything in neuroscience
and you might learn something about this
lobe
or that that cortex region but then only
to find out that
later on a year later like well actually
it seems like it's also communicating
over here
it's a spider web of unbelievable
intelligence it's happening
that and everything can be millisecond
hundreds of million seconds
of transitions between neural networks
it's unbelievably fast
unbelievable capable so this is just for
our understanding
it's not necessarily real world linear
like this
but what tends to happen is as
information comes in good
bad we also then move it to
a level of well what does this mean to
me identity
what does this mean to me what does this
either mean to me or what does this
say about me how does this apply to me
and if we're not conscious here this can
be really troublesome some of you
discovered that yesterday i bet when you
released a few things
sometimes we have these events in our
life that we we take on and we just
assume it meant something about us
and we didn't realize no that's more of
a statement about them than it is about
us
right sometimes when you're hurt or
someone was rude to you it had
nothing to do with you raise your hand
you follow i had nothing to do with you
but if you're not careful you could say
mean person unsafe means i'm bad child
rude behavior uncertain about this i
must not be long
terrible situation i feel bad
i can never be safe again how many
follow how this happens
this is why we have to be very very very
observational of our own thoughts and
feelings because
how these things get labeled can really
change our lives forever
well imagine like last night i'm going
on the stage right if i
if my identity says i am a public
speaker
and it's important for me to be
excellent at this and then i go on stage
and i bomb
what does that say about me as a person
so we've got about 50 years of work in
psychology
in the field of psychology saying do not
tie your efforts to your identity
because that risk of disappointment or
rejection
you know if the task fails you shouldn't
take that as as a defining moment in
which you
say i am a failure right so that's the
risk and that's what you know
psychologists tell us
to be wary of except it turns out that
high performers flipped out on
its face and go well actually um
no i do get bothered if it fails
i really get upset about it i am
attached to
the process here i i do care if it turns
out
well i mean that's why they obsess about
the details that's why they care about
excellence it's like
no one obsessed about the details or
cares about excellence unless it means
something to them
and there is a risk the risk is you over
attach to the process of the outcome
with your identity so that if the
process or outcome goes bad now you feel
bad about yourself
as a human and now you stop your
progress
but i also tell people there's a balance
there
i actually wish more people would attach
some identity to what they're doing
they wouldn't go through the motions as
much i mean i think
what the world needs less of is half
interested parents
who don't have an identity that says you
know what i'm going to be an excellent
parent
i think we have a lot of ceos or
business people or entrepreneurs
who they've never stepped in and said
you know what i'm a ceo
i own this business i am responsible for
paying the bills i am responsible for
making the money i'm responsible for
all these people's mortgages who work
for me like they
i want them to own the identity of a ceo
because
most of them if you ask them about their
identity and their business they're kind
of like
you come to find they're kind of
approaching it like
not even hobbyists it's like if you want
to win
your identity has to be tied into that
thing in which you are trying to succeed
at
and give to and that takes a lot of guts
to put yourself all in for something but
who's ever contributed something with
tremendous impact without being
all into it i've never seen it so i
think the message of the book
you're right i'll get some flack of a
lot of psychologists say don't don't
tell people to tie more of their
identity
or my friends who are buddhists will say
but attachment is the form of all
suffering brennan have you not read your
spiritual attacks i'm like look out
calm down i've hung out with the dalai
lama i'm totally cool
but what i'm trying to tell you is even
the dalai lama
has a connection with himself as a
spiritual leader
his identity is still there that people
you know assume that you know we have to
release ourselves from having any
attachment to something but i'm like
i think we all want to be present and
engaged
fully in the things that we are doing in
our lives
and that's going to require us to say
psychologically you know what i
i am all in this
that's what i'm about it's the habit is
generate energy
okay not necessarily have energy create
energy create energy and what they do
the way we measure that was kind of
academic mental
energy which is tied to your focus and
your stamina
and your ability to manage complex tasks
without too much mental stress
number two is emotional energy which is
just the quality of positive emotions
and number three is physical energy high
performers
are 40 more likely to work out five
times per week
than the rest of their peers so that
means the top
15 most high performing people in the
world
tend to work out five days per week and
that workout could be defined as you
know 45 minute brisk walk or
you know hit intensity or whatever it is
but 40 percent more likely that's a huge
finding
and what we found is high performers
just have better well-being
and happiness and physical conditioning
than everybody else
one stunning finding was uh
ceos senior executives and business
owners
they report expending as much energy
as athletes who are competitive now i
can imagine
yeah yeah i kind of i was surprised by
that i thought you know
athletes would be ten percent more i
mean the emotional and mental energy
yeah
the decision making the conversations
the big deals the
steakness yeah there's a lot of energy
it's a lot that's why
i mean if you really want to achieve
your dreams you have to
care for your body yeah your mind it's
why all these things you know
finally resonating in the marketplace
because the science of meditation
or taking a break or you know uh
managing your own energy sleep is
everything yeah
um and i think all of that is really
important and we say generate energy
because there's this myth that
you know some people have happiness or
they have it's like
no you generate you don't have happiness
you generally create it yeah you create
it and so
the quality of your energy you have to
create like you and i both
i mean if most of our audience knew our
schedules your schedule the last five
days was like how is lewis even
able to focus right now and how are you
able to get here and and do this as well
yeah but it's because we say well this
is our mission show up man
yeah there's plenty of times i gotta
imagine you walked on the field and you
were like
i'm exhausted you know i remember when
you like flew down to compete
i still play with the usa team handball
yeah team and a year ago i
i flew down to i remember i did an
interview
in miami and then flew out from miami
and then went
and just went right into training camp
and then played against brazil which is
like
you know olympic olympic qualifiers and
yeah got our assets booked but it was
fun you know
but i had to have clarity yeah yeah she
didn't show up even when i was like oh
we're gonna lose yeah like there's deer
a chance
yeah it was like the worst team in the
nba playing like the warriors and we
were just like
we had no chance yeah but i had to show
up and give my best and
you have to set all these routine i mean
you know the amount of routines
tom brady has in his life so that he can
generate energy it's unbelievable
stuns most people it's unbelievable and
that's just that that's that's what it
takes if you want to get that level if
you don't want to be at that level you
don't have to do it
yeah you don't have to do it i mean
everybody can just like well i'm going
to go you know hit the cinnabon but it's
like
it's pretty good how do you want to feel
at three o'clock if you want to feel
amazing at three o'clock don't end lunch
with a cinnabon
one of the major major keys we found the
first high performing habit
is seek clarity and what we found
is one of the practices that high
performers do
is they define the feeling they're after
and so when we had to explain that and
later
talk about it in the energy chapter we
had to differentiate between feelings
and emotions and they are different
emotions tend to be they're the same
like we ha they're physical they're
almost always automatic even though when
the brain is creating associations has
also happened
for us it's kind of emotion comes up
yeah you're watching a movie and you're
just sad and you're like oh my gosh you
know i'm crying
you didn't even have the tissues right
you're just like you know uh
but the feelings are usually
interpretations that we make
of what that emotion was and how it
sticks and the meaning we give it to it
yeah and the example i used
you know i like to give and i don't
remember if it's in the book or not
honestly because here's what's happened
this book is 400 pages it was 1481 when
i finished
baby you edited it down yes and it was
1481
good complete like it was like awesome
yes but i was like that's going to freak
people out so we're publishing a bunch
in academic journals later and then
stripped it down to 400 pages so it's
more readable and fun and orientable so
i can't remember if this one actually
made it in there but
um the example i like to give is if you
and i go to
a haunted house yeah which i love i love
them i love them and they scare me the
crap but if
you and i walk around you know you walk
around on the walls in a haunted house
someone jumps out at you yeah you and i
are both going to jump
yes we are emotionally going to
experience fright
immediately it's going to be there right
but i might be
freaked out for the next five minutes
and you might be laughing
why it's the meaning and the feeling
that we've defined it as
that's fine for everybody here's the
issue that people have and you have to
be careful about
when we start talking about energy
because emotional energy is real yes
and that is look if at six like we go to
the haunted house
at you know 5 p.m in the afternoon if at
9 pm now you're in your house
you're alone but you're completely safe
and you still
feel scared that's not the haunted
house's problem
that is the way that you are defining
and working through your own emotions
you had the emotion of terror and fear
and you're still
experiencing that feeling that's a
mental job
not an emotional job so your job is to
go wow
i'm at my house i i've lived here for 10
years i've never been threatened this
house this is a safe place
i got to redefine the feeling i want to
experience and i work with one
an olympic sprinter gold medalist
olympic sprinter
as a client and this person's huge
breakthrough in getting better and going
from
literally uh one olympics before
not meddling at all to now gold i said
what made
like what was the thing yeah and one of
the things they said to me was
i learned to define the feeling
and i said what do you mean by that and
he basically said you know
if if if there's a bunch of us at the
starting box and we're all in perfect
poise in perfect condition
the one to bet on is the one that says
this is the way i want to feel in this
race right now
i know my emotions are going crazy like
my heart's beating i can hear
everybody i'm waiting for that shot
blast i can see my goal
i know how important this is and all
these like
their emotions are there yeah but that
person is defining the feeling
i'm going to feel centered now
i'm going to get myself in the zone now
even though the anxiety is
the emotion of anxiety is there for all
olympic level
competitors all of them but they define
that feat that emotion
as a feeling that helps give them a
performance edge
and i think that's important too you
know bruce springsteen says if he's ever
backstage and doesn't feel
like nerves he's gonna hang it up yeah
but that's anxiety he's just defining it
differently it's so simple
like when you get the life is really
short and you felt that before
either by you were threatened or you've
had some near near and dear die
but when you have that real essence in
you that says life is short have
reverence for it live it
that's a really big thing i got that at
19 and i learned specifically
that if we have a moment of cognition
before the end of our life
we tend to ask questions to evaluate if
we're happy
so if i have any impact in the world
it's
going to come from that experience where
i learned that the ultimate lesson is
determine what the questions you're
going to ask at the end of your life are
going to be
find out those questions what will you
ask at the end of your life
to evaluate your life so that you would
know if you were happy with your life
like
figure out those questions and then live
each day intentionally so you're happy
with the answers at the end
for me the answers the questions i had
were did i live
which i hadn't i hadn't been living my
life i'd been thinking about taking my
life
did i love no my heart was broken
and i put up all these walls to keep out
other people and i always say you know
sometimes the walls we put up
to keep out the bad guys prevent the
good guys from getting in
and suddenly in our own self-protection
we block out the very thing we want
which is connection
and i learned that i would ask did i
matter
you know 22 years ago on a dark
caribbean night i'm standing on
the crumpled hood of a car bleeding out
my friend and i just wrecked a car
he's screaming at top of his lungs he's
bleeding we know if we're going to live
and i'm standing on this car looking
down all this blood
and i'm in terror and i just remember
looking down at the hood and just
thinking
did i even matter you know
and i hated the answer at that time in
life because a 19 year old kid
i didn't know about impact theory for
real
i didn't know to think about that you
some you know young kids sometimes they
don't know to think about that
i didn't know to think about legacy
meaning did i matter i didn't think i
did
but the good news is i'm a good learner
and i felt like i got a second chance
from god that night and
i learned that it was really important
for me
to figure out how do i live and how do i
love and how do i matter in such a way
that if i face my death again
i'll know i've earned the second chance
and so what i want to tell people and
the impact i want is i just want people
to
know
know your questions man live
intentionally and earn the life that
you've been given because this moment's
a blessing
so earn this moment and live
intentionally dude if you're
angry all the time you got to change how
you look at the world
yes there's a lot in the news that can
piss you off yes there's a lot going on
that
causes outrage all day long on twitter
or social media somewhere
but if that's your sole focus no wonder
you're upset all the time
lots of people are angry right now
because of the news or something
chaotic or terrible or something they
don't agree with is happening in the
world
but that's not new there's always chaos
there's always turmoil there's always
bad things happen in the world
but if that's your focus no wonder
you're having that anxiety
and that frustration and that anger all
the time
you got to change both your focus and
how you're reacting to things when you
do see it
so first let's work on your focus you
know are as much as you're angry all the
time
are you also noticing the beauty of this
world
i mean the odds that you're even alive
and having your breath
is something to connect to every single
morning to have reverence for your life
in the morning to wake up you know one
of my late mentors was
wayne dyer an amazing amazing teacher
and he always talked about how
he woke up he rolled over he put his
feet on the ground and he said
thank you thank you thank you
he was grateful for his day and he began
that way
and i think so many people right now
they kind of roll up in bed and they're
like
and they grab their freaking phone and
they start going through the news on
social media and what are they
cueing immediately i'm cueing stress
chaos turmoil
clickables you know it's like click make
look at me click clickbait
no wonder you're frustrated you're
activating your brain immediately
right off the beginning of the day in
all the turmoil of the world put the
dang phone down
get up and think about what you're
grateful for about what you want to
achieve and give and serve and create
that day about who needs you to be on
your a game that day
so you can focus on that instead of like
this in bed
that will change how you start your day
and then listen a lot of people who are
angry all the time
they're also in outrage all the time
because they're focusing on
the problem all the time and they're
bemoaning the problem
they're calling out the problem
complaining about the problem
judging criticizing getting upset all
the time a ton of people who stay in
anger all the time
are failing to be solution based
that's what they're doing right they're
just anger anger problem problem problem
problem outrage
outrage but listen when you become a
solution based person when you say
okay i actually want to do something
about this problem and you start taking
positive steps to at least address it or
to participate
suddenly that anger goes into a new fire
and that fire is called enthusiasm
it is easy to switch anger into
enthusiasm
when you become solution based as a
mindset when you say okay
i don't like this let me do something
let me let me call somebody let me take
this action let me write that letter let
me send that email let me get my friends
together
let's go protest let's go get involved
let's participate
because participation turns anger
often into enthusiasm and so if you're
just stewing on the things you don't
like of course
it's going to be a negative energy but
if you start stewing on the things that
you can
do you find personal power you find
enthusiasm you find social contribution
ultimately you find community because
one reason it's so easy to be
angry is when you're alone you're at
home
you're sort of thinking and thinking and
thinking and thinking about all the
negative things
and you don't have an outlet of other
human beings to discuss with
especially solution oriented people or
people with ideas and dreams and
ambitions
people who are doing stuff with their
life because listen
when you're on a path of purpose you
ain't got time for drama
i don't have time for a ton of anger in
my life because i'm too busy making
positive changes
that's where we want to get you we want
to shift your attention and focus in the
morning we want to start making you more
solution
based and get your community of people
around who are
ambitious and driven to change and to
make positive change happen when we do
that
the anger starts going away and if you
can't get over the anger yourself
then don't be shy about asking for help
you know a lot of people they don't have
anybody to talk to so
i'm like get a therapist man get in a
group man
talk with some people go to a seminar
get in a new sort of environment
you want to get rid of the anger go
volunteer get around other people who
are making positive impacts that
community
that shift changes your life you don't
have to be
angry anymore and the last part about
that
is letting go you got to let go of those
things that upset you three years ago
five years ago 10 years ago
if you're an adult and you're still
angry and pissed about things that
happen to you in
high school you need a therapist and i
say that with all
sincerity and all respect if you're
having
mental thoughts that are coming from a
place that are literally based
5 10 20 years ago that you just didn't
deal with yet
you need help dealing with it and you
need to get yourself a meditation
practice or a therapist or in some kind
of way that
you're on a consistent basis letting
things go here's what i do
every sunday i go okay what was i pissed
about this last week what really
bothered me
okay i gotta let that go because you
can't keep charging
into the next week angry from last week
you gotta let it go you gotta find a
clean slate for yourself
so that your your soul can expand and
can be positive
and can be ambitious and motivated and
serving the next week
because listen anger after anger after
anger
hatred after hatred after hatred
criticism after criticism after
criticism rejection after rejection
after rejection
outrage after outrage after outrage it
weighs you
down so you've got to change how much of
that you're taking
in and you've got to make sure every
single week you're doing some kind of
like mental detox
to let that stuff go and instead of
cultivating the anger
cultivate the gratitude cultivate the
enthusiasm
and you can change your life if you want
more inspiration morning videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it
it's right there next to me go click it
there continue to believe
and i'll see you there